now i'm just getting [ __ ]  angry out here like [ __ ] really  spend all their time talking about how  to control [ __ ] they can't [ __ ]  control and won't talk about the [ __ ]  that they aren't doing to do something  about it people looking at the garage  sale videos and being like yeah but the  taxes and the gas but you could go  harder you could go thursday night to  thrift stores friday to estate sales  saturday to garage sales sunday to  second day garage sales but you won't  talk about that you won't talk about the  [ __ ] that you're [ __ ] responsible for  you're gonna go blame some macro  geopolitics  and tell me why you [ __ ] can't you  might be tricking the other [ __ ]  losers you hang out with but you're not  shrinking a [ __ ] winning player with  this [ __ ] addiction to excuse after  excuse about some [ __ ] that they'll  never [ __ ] affect affect your [ __ ]  self  [ __ ]